pfff vous ce samedi avec cavalerie
précis mais en fait c'est un concours au
15 rue et on aura déjà les premières
chansons car la balle dans la centrale
pendant la période qui ont renchéri de
suite après avec
on a fait un pas rares dans le 14
janvier et dans toutes ses
manifestations
une organisation bien particulière pour
le carnaval
oui absolument pas ce que c'est une
organisation où il faut à la fois
composer avec des associations qui sont
des bénévoles et professionnels
l'encadrement alors c'est vraiment
l'esprit kurdes ont en général toute
façon bientôt marcheront dur comme on
dit chez nous et cette organisation là
même si elle est présente mais elle est
satisfaisante avec le visage pour vous
c'est inciter le maximum de personnes à
participer à la fête
oui oui absolument parce que c'est un
moment où on est en communion avec nous
même si c'est un moment où il n'y a pas
de barrières sociales ou les petits les
grands les personnes âgées et que ce
soit le milieu social on est ensemble ça
il n'y a pas de différence
quoique le canada véritablement ces
moments à partager la terre vie mais je
crois qu'au niveau 33 tours tout faux
pas ce soir niveau si vous disiez
premier rendez vous ce samedi
concrètement c'est quoi alors ce
rendez-vous qui s'appelle cavendish
festival donc on incite le groupe à
faire des chansons allaient présenter
parce que mon cas d'indivision les
gentils plus comme avant elle est
présentée et aussi à demander au public
de choisir la meilleure chanson qu'on
fait sept enfants courent de la caisse
de fruits ou leur chance et de l'inde
les maths cera et mary